let's get this over with
43 seconds of logos tom tasks when
you're the eighth movie of a franchise
and your production company is called
original film what point do you consider
a name change also you have a goosebumps
equal and a Sonic the Hedgehog movie
coming out soon so it's time to invest
in a you and an end for your name in
case you confused it with Havana India
you see it's different this time because
they're using classic cars this time
make God deal Dom's in a new country in
this chapter so therefore the movie has
to manufacture some bull conflict so we
can get a classic fast and furious
racing before it becomes xxx ocean's 17
identity he knows it doesn't matter
what's under a hood the only thing that
matters is who's behind the wheel okay
then I'd like to see you race this guy
driving a 1985 Toyota Camry racing a
mile it's like a baker's dozen only with
empanadas instead of donuts dumb Donald
race to race this asshole and this
dilapidated old truck because the movie
is unsure if the audience realizes how
good a driver Dom really is so the
stakes against him have to keep going up
even past the point of insanity
laughing us nah this is Cuban Nos is
there a difference between Cuban nos and
regular nas I thought nah stood for a
nitrous oxide like as in if it were any
different it would no longer be nos but
some other compound entirely conspicuous
cocaine confounds consumers calculating
cola comparisons a Cuban mild on I
wonder what the casting call is like for
the flag girls in this franchise like
they must tell them you won't be in any
other movies after this but on the plus
side you'll get to show your ass to
everybody this is broad daylight
I realize Cuba's a foreign communist
country but I still don't think they
allow Havana streets to be shut down for
drag races without some cops showing up
motorcycle traffic Stoppers look out by
getting a wide space to stop traffic in
time and not get run over
how have they not already gone a mile
yeah yeah I know it's a Cuban mile but
they're not already gone the amount of
distance I think of Cuban mile is okay
this works this works it's not enough
for Tom to win this race with a bad car
it also has to catch fire before the
finish line this is all these movies
summed up in one scene honestly also
sure this car can drive and drive fast
while on fire
it's just Cuban fire cue movie yeah but
they have this slow tech not want you to
figure out if Tom actually won you know
it would have been more awesome to
actually see the car at full speed crash
into the water without five cuts what is
this mother Gandhi now you won my car my
respect
I'll bet ten thousand dollars right now
Tom ask this guy for a favor before the
end of the movie Jaws was too slow for
Toretto anyway so let that be a lesson
to you kids you can somehow make a deal
with a gangster not fulfill your end of
the bargain have a cousin who just
happens to be in your hometown who's a
legendary street racer try to race your
peace car against the gangsters car and
a terrible disadvantage had your cousin
destroy that car during the race then
have the same cousin give you his
awesome car and have absolutely no
consequences at all
they keep trying to invent new ways to
keep all these movies titles confusing
and overlapping fate rhymes with 8
hilarious ah Letty and Dom's love the
heart and soul of this entire four hey
wait a second
how's that honeymoon going down Seifer
decides the best way to get Dom's
attention is to fake a breakdown
rather than go to some of the many
places she's about to rattle off that
she knows Dom goes to everyday is this
the road you take to your apartment
every morning what else is different Dom
Santiago's closed
how does Dom who has no job and is
simply hanging out in Cuba have a
predictable routine every morning
oh and Dom so I heard cypher open the
door to her car I'm pretty sure she
never closed that hood also she shows
him something on the phone that we don't
see that causes him to betray his
friends and family I think it's pretty
clear she showed him the sins video for
Furious 7 movies continue to think we
need to know the longitude and latitude
of a new place during a scene change the
rock coaches girls soccer was probably a
movie idea at one time during that Tooth
Fairy phase thank God we finally got to
see a nod to that cinematic greatness
here movie that is over two hours has
time for this hey Hobbes this important
world crisis needed to be brought to
your attention at the soccer game not
before not after but now dammit I
look at I mean he's just how the
openings in case you confused it with
Berlin of take my breath away Fang also
here's the job Dom and his crew are on
mid operation we don't need to know how
they stole the EMP or what the plan was
because this movie is way more
interested in dropping surprise plot
twists and girls soccer on you than
giving you details of a heist or
character motivations also also why did
the movie give us that scene showing
Charlize talking to DOM now we know to
expect something weird from him imagine
if we experienced this job the way his
teammates do and learn of his deception
on the spot that would have been way
better bombs away
seriously how did the team get in here
and set up all these bombs and gadgets
without anyone seeing it and this mugger
is attached to a wrecking ball I don't
care how he did it someone would have
noticed also why not set up bombs on the
roadway instead of hoping the wrecking
ball plan works oh it's so we can see
all those cars get hit by a wrecking
ball isn't it alright earn that paycheck
Tyreese by the way considering they
didn't tell him about the wrecking ball
plan couldn't have like died Hobbs
survives all kinds of this oh great
another airstrip I wonder if this one's
also twenty-two miles long
barely a car trip Lane can just land on
a dime going whatever speed it was going
allow a car to drive onto it and fly
straight up into the air with its rear
cargo entrance still open and no one in
the control tower was able to ID that
planes transponder signal or decipher
where it went after this using radar
honestly this movie suggests a
successful takeoff is all this plane
needs to get away with it but that's not
how airspace works Germany would be
scrambling some fighters right about now
why did lady go to Berlin bring keepsake
pictures of her and DOM and put them in
the glove box of the borrowed or stolen
vehicle she drove during the robbery Dom
is clearly communicating with somebody
that's above hey hey remember when they
introduced Ramsay Bolton
I mean missandei to the Fast and Furious
crew and she was some badass hacker or
some yeah they still haven't given or
anything to do ecords in the same prison
what are the odds that Hercules I love
our characters in both Central
Intelligence and fate of the Furious
refer to the rock as Hercules as if this
meta joke is something side-splitting
Lee hilarious this prisoner rivalry is
still going on cuz we run from we don't
settle fights by throwing bomb that's
funny because we're on from
[Music]
what what
also if teasing one sells camera
electrical thing he opens all the cells
then the designer of this prison is
facing a serious lawsuit after this is
editing and this camera works the rock
sponges are made of dynamite or a
sharknado or some omnipotence this
pronounced makes me wonder why you can't
steal the MacGuffin thing back via your
own general godlike abilities rather
than recruiting a bunch of car thieves a
location so undisclosed the movie
doesn't even know six eight nine ten so
literally half the Interpol top ten is
made up of members of this group is that
even possible
listen TP Cooper still out there her
digital identity is scrub every few
seconds worldwide what also despite this
we knew who we were looking for when we
took this picture of her I'm bringing in
an extra pair of hands you know your
mortal enemy that's a big surprise which
definitely builds trust between all of
us
I had him waiting outside until I gave
him an electric shock to cue him into
the room also this franchise is
officially Pirates of the Caribbean
where everybody changes they're good guy
and bad guy status TIFF it's some sort
of crazy-ass narrative and somehow this
secret government doesn't have anyone as
good as this guy with computers now
aside from myself there's only two men
in the world that I've ever managed to
actually track him down with any success
plus one woman so that's four people at
least so he apparently isn't that hard
to find but sure we still need shown for
some reason so like it or not you two
are gonna work together it's just like
in all those other movies that pairing
up to cops criminals that hated each
other he still dreams yeah like fresh
babies alright they're not in China
thanks for holding our hand during this
stage Europe's ku2 girl they sometimes
give lines too this is interesting why
because that's here you means Dom and
cypher were attacking this place at the
same time they were being tracked
what great dramatic timing Dom shoots a
whole bunch of glance for some reason as
if he lives his life 3/4 through the
script of die hard at a time we're
supposed to be reminded that DOM is now
evil but everything about this movie
tells me he's just faking and will turn
good at the last second so like this is
lost on me we can't bring Brian and me
into this can't you just make a phone
call
do they even have to be dragged into the
situation to help problem with putting
your foot on the tightest neck as you
could never let it out the problem with
lines like this is the movie thinks
they're cool sounding which they're not
but also that they make no goddamn sense
oh but Selena from
which one was it I think it's the third
one no it's a fourth one for sure wait
it might even be the fifth one a baby so
I guess that YouTube video she showed
him earlier in Cuba was of this gal in
captivity even so how was that enough to
get Dom to go 100% rogue to the point
where he wouldn't even tip off Letty or
the other somehow unexpected Elena
everyone else was pregnant
you had just fun though lady was alive
this is where the Fast and Furious
franchise officially became the days of
our lives
it's amazing how sidekicks be getting
pregnant just before the last time you
saw them Vin Diesel's Oscar clip say
forgives down a gun and goes through all
the reasons why he won't kill her
ultimately saying there's a bunch of
dudes ready to kill the son you didn't
know you had up until two minutes ago I
don't know why she even bothered with
this exercise since I thought it was
already common knowledge but bloated
movies got a bloat yo satellites and
radar grids all across the globe shit
like an ocean if you say so so you know
where DOM is headed yeah
New York wait I see online chatting with
somebody who knew where tom was headed
did he post a query on Usenet or some it
would be a lot more awesome to know how
he did this even if you had to go
through some sort of ant-man explanation
speeding like this on this famous bridge
brings out zero cops
we're Tom just happens to be driving
over a bridge that Roman and Tesh are
currently driving under that may be the
least believable moment in this movie
including the submarine crap welcome to
our new base of operations
aka God's car warehouse yes The Fast &
Furious series has always been about
cars but this is pushing it to some
total bullshit
this is like all the cars it's neon
orange so choose anything less
conspicuous dude this entire warehouse
of cars has nothing conspicuous I like
your beard your planta black Santa
I gotta need him
daaamn can see this ATM from here which
is fine my gas but where is it you and I
both know there's no et I'm outside that
red building there we find out later
that Dom got helped to block the ATM
camera so that he could set up some plan
with Sean's mom but how did he
communicate his plan with everybody when
he's being monitored are you saying that
cypher trust Domino to allow him to
communicate to people unmonitored
whatever the case may be he orchestrated
impossible connections in an impossible
amount of time to give you something
back there is no way Dom does this in
five minutes I mean coming up gone and
I'm gonna knock your teeth so far down
your throat you're gonna stick a
toothbrush right up your ass to brush
him movie believes that we anticipate a
rock Statham fights so much that we'll
be delighted with several scenes devoted
to dick swinging the gods I really is
the only true conclusion to Hollywood
zoom an enhance obsession it was always
gonna end this way it's zombie time oh
it was a zombie time by the fourth or
fifth movie but at least you're finally
acknowledging it why do you even need
Dom let alone badly need him for this
job let's watch it I guess this is kind
of cool and all but this is a super
complicated way to get what you want if
you've got God's eye you can find anyone
anywhere in the world with our
connections and know how did it really
require a bunch of hacked cars crashing
into him to get what she wants
take out the lead and follow cars
luckily there's a car dealership full of
cars we can hack the
[Music]
remember this is all just to steal a
case from one man
overkill watched this movie and walked
down after finding it excessive now
that's dumb it's actually not though
Dom hasn't done dick yet it's actually
1,000 autonomous car controlled by
Charlize and one hacker guy and Dom is
just kind of following along and
watching but whatever even after that
repeated lecture about choosing
inconspicuous cars all these mothers
drive out into battle in the most
conspicuous cars ever and all that car
control utter bull technobabble is just
to set up this raining car shot and
sometimes guys the visual is not worth
the flimsy explanation you weave for it
all so seriously there are this many
cars that you can hack remotely
I don't doubt there would be a lot this
movie makes it sound like every single
car everyone drives is hooked up to a
network target immobilized
oh she needed 1,000 cars to immobilize
the Russian guy but DOM is
super-important as the guy that then
goes in to grab the case any hired goon
could take over here lady the more this
series focuses on spectacle the more
they raise the middle finger to people
who want even a sliver of logic or
consistency in the case this is how the
usual suspects foiled New York's finest
taxi service only way louder and
stupider
[Music]
and I won't be needing this anymore I
think in the warmer tunes I wear right
in front of me
I mean God these movies everything has
to be some sort of reveal looking for
someone there in the building right now
found your team make your boss gasp
before revealing they're here right now
he's got a saying he start a new kissing
or what first of all the police even
broadcast that panic-inducing
information on channels they know some
citizens and journalists are listening
to also how would anyone know that this
soon after it happened in order to even
broadcasted on police scanners in the
first place I don't know it's funnier
but there's nobody who needs to go down
this street or that this guy just
totally ran a red light and didn't give
a fuck or these people casually sitting
down next to the cars watching the movie
if only there were cops in this city
this is so clearly impossible that the
filmmakers cut several times during this
book to cover up all the times this car
crash doing the stunts let me put
together the scene and it's clearly
never driven in Manhattan before miles
of open road enough to stare down at
your ex enough to engage the nos somehow
of all the stupid they tossed out in
brainstorming for this movie car harpoon
still made the final cut or carpoon if
you will I love how these movies show
cars that are clearly already going as
fast as they can complete with a nonce
injection and yet there's always another
gear that these assholes can try like
there's a theoretical notch on the stick
that summons Dumbledore to make your
ride sicker about 2,000 horsepower in
that thing
try whatever it is it's bull five
government made cars can't stop this
thing also does nobody have a gun that
can shoot out the tires go well Dom to
speak reacting to fake killing Deckard
let it be ninjas up on him and steals
the case somehow you can in town feel
bad for Charlize Theron's in this movie
because for half of it she's by herself
looking at a screen delivering pointless
lines I don't know why you're doing this
but I know one thing
you better have a previously heretofore
unknown young son being held hostage or
so help me God I will just take it from
a dead girl love is what finally makes
Dom abandon his evil character and Brik
good love for Letty over love for his
son or something I don't really think
character motivation is something these
movies give much thought to Deckard he
didn't make it
movie flat-out lies to you to set up a
stupid reveal later but also why are
they sad about deckert's death he was
the villain in the last movie they don't
exactly love that guy right
[Music]
so I turned off all the lights and
waited until you got here to set up the
surprise I'm gonna kill your baby party
[Music]
this kid would not be calling Dom Dada
on his second encounter with him this is
one of the cheapest ploys to pull
audience heartstrings ever no now
they're gonna have to find a babysitter
Connor wait
he's also linked to somebody I'd quite
like to forget this movie just became
Spectre all of a sudden hey you remember
all those characters from previous
chapters they're all tied to one main
baddie somehow even though that's
clearly impossible taking your son got
me the cards no cards well get me the
nukes yeah but shouldn't you have done
something with those codes as soon as
you got them you know besides setting up
that elaborate threat to kill Dom's baby
mama and kid doesn't Russian know that
somebody has their codes and are
changing them at this very second or
nuclear codes that insecure that if they
got stolen someone really has this kind
of power the problem we've had with
tracking cipher is there's nothing to
trace except for the satellite blind
spots that jason statham figured out to
track Dom's secret flight to New York
City but he didn't bother teaching
anyone that so I guess that knowledge
died with him we got to call this in all
the way up the chain but unfortunately
the Russian Minister of Defense got
himself involved a little incident on
u.s. territory and two governments
aren't talking to each other for a while
but who so you shouldn't even try is it
really that simple of a reason come on
we're talking about goddamn stolen
nuclear codes here not shooting down a
spy plane pray that the apocalypse
doesn't come knocking on your mama's
front door
the rock has reverted back to full WWE
mode these days and it's movies are
suffering for it take whatever vehicle
you want all bets are off
yeah but you're going to ice Russia and
yet some of these fools will still
choose Lambos and stupid act like that
[Music]
do they parachute these cars on top of
this mountain are you telling me Russian
airspace is this awful they didn't spot
a large cargo plane flying through here
or that the separatists who control this
base somehow missed them yep about to
drive dangerously on ice and snow in a
goddamn Lambo
commonsense be damned again and left for
dead on the side of the road I mean
really only three of the five heroes
make sensible snow vehicle choices I
tried to take a piss I recognize that's
a dick joke right there
if dcmp is as powerful as this movie
says it is then why doesn't it also stop
Dom's car dead in its tracks you know
since it's on top of it I think cycle
just rebooted that sub to slave its
commands sister crate are you telling me
this nuclear submarine can be remotely
hacked just because cipher used the EMP
a nuclear submarine seriously if you can
get me into that wheel house I can tap
the network and counter hack cipher look
I know this car was made by God or
whatever but now it's able to crash into
a building and an armored truck like
they're not even there don't look the
bad guys are at a facility that has all
these exposed gas tanks around so things
can explode easily isn't that nice knock
knock open up the door it's real who is
where you don't care guys oh just tired
actively hope Dom dies or at the very
least fails every time he does a stunt
like this on top of this he even kills a
ton of bad guys in the process it can't
be this good or lucky it takes all the
tension out of the scenes when the guy
doesn't ever lose how do you like this
well it's taken roughly a movie and a
half for Ramsey to actually do anything
and we know she's a crazy good hacker I
find it extraordinarily laughable that
she could counter hack cipher this
quickly since she's supposed to be
equally good not better hi Vamsi and
then she counter counter hacks and I
wonder how these two amazing hackers
don't have any protections in play when
they're off doing their hacking yeah my
computer can totally show you detailed
heat maps of people running around
inside a nuclear sub
[Music]
gods I my ass
she's just God by the way all this
punching and kicking and yelling is just
doing anything for you these are the
scenes with the characters who have
nothing to do or insert it into the
action to fight basically faceless
drones inducing yawning he's knocked me
out weird that she didn't do that before
what in the hell are you guys doing
it'll be labeled guidance go why didn't
you say that in the first place yep
you've got the upper hand on one person
when your entire base just got done time
for a good cackle which will ultimately
lead to your demise this is like the guy
who sacks the backup quarterback in the
fourth quarter in a game his team is
losing 67 to 3 and we have a countdown
I'd like to remind at this point that
cypher got access to this missile
because she stole nuclear codes from a
Russian Minister of Defense the space
was taken over by Russian separatists
and yet the Russian government was still
in control of those missiles apparently
they didn't bother to change or remove
those codes from the nuclear football
when those guys took over I find that
unlikely but ain't I guess stupid things
happen in the real world all the time
we got the chip no nukes for her what
are you a nuke Nazi God we got company
a lot of company a lot of military
company are they supporting Charlize or
just defending a Russian base who knows
who cares and who let the dogs out you
have no sympathy from me Tyreese you
chose the Lambo knowing you were headed
to ice Russia personally I feel like
this is payback for years of coasting on
your part despite the fact that Roman is
comically spinning on the ice the
Russian terrorist guys can't hit it or
really anybody they're kind of a
terrible group of thugs actually I don't
even know how they took this base over
in the first place well we contemplate
whether DOM wants to put this car in
gear who's taking care of his kit it's
there really a bad guy who's feeding his
son and changing diapers I would love to
see that movie oh wait maybe not forget
what I said
tange starts blasting away and instantly
hits one of the trucks something that
none of the assholes behind him could do
for a full minute of blasting I don't
look this one is going to take out more
trucks reminds me of that old adage life
is always fair and full of constitute
good luck
okay so how's he holding on to the
outside of the door remember the doors
closed until the tank rips it off so
once that tears off he better be holding
on to the inside of it or else he's done
for maybe once it rips off he grabs the
outside but that would be an incredible
feat considering the speed at which all
this takes place come on guys kill him
sweep the leg if DOM is constantly being
monitored on this operation then how is
he getting away with these obvious
shenanigans
okay so Dom shot Deckard earlier and to
no one's surprise except cypher he's
still alive my question is how did they
plan this remember all this
how did Dom know it would come to this
as luck would have it this entire scene
leads to the moment where Deckard is
able to chase him to a secluded area to
fake his death also with God's eye how
did cypher not track every movement
Deckard made until she could confirm his
death see I told you but hilariously the
movie made him so paper-thin in the
opening scene it doesn't trust you to
remember his face and has to literally
show you who he is also you movie you
mean DOM ask this guy from the beginning
to fly from Cuba all the way to New York
City to do five minutes worth of work
doesn't Dom have like closer connections
who could easily do this job
congratulations Dom you just killed your
son no stupid his cipher right now she
saw the transporter and bard the Bowman
three minutes ago does she really think
Dom would be so arrogant if he didn't
have his son secured you're wrong I just
saved by the way to play the devil's
advocate here and I will since charlize
theron is in this movie DOM is still
owing to arrogant here dealing with
cypher for all he knows she's crazy
enough to crash the plane with her the
Shah brothers and his son on it what
would you know we start crying
fast and furious crew must have started
praying because dawn in his supercar a
literal day who sex machina comes to the
rescue
also they made a car that is too awesome
in this movie no flaws whatsoever
you're literally Superman in this car
not setting the baby down before
fighting god damn this scene seemed just
broke the encounter meanwhile a movie
still has the audacity to steal the kid
has headphones on during the gunfight
scene from face off how did the
submarine catch up to the cars if you're
telling me the cars are only going 40
miles an hour okay maybe I'll believe
you look they're going pretty much full
speed as best they can hour tops correct
we got this are you okay are you okay
breathing Dom foolishly believes this
indestructible car can be destroyed by a
heat-seeking missile it could just put
this in park and watch the thing
harmlessly glance off the sideview
mirror well they finally did it the Fast
and Furious franchise just jumped us up
no no you this movie
that is not how fire works a handful of
cars around a guy generally will not
save said guy from damage during a
raging explosion fire just FYI how did
you find me if Dom gave cypher a
necklace by which Deckard could track
her oh I didn't he pass this information
on to his team as well they lucked out
finding her in Russia by guessing her
most logical target but that would have
been really handy information to have no
matter what
why did Deckard's death need to be a
surprise to the team there's only one
flaw in your plan what's that that's
extremely presumptuous on your part but
anything that gets us closer to the
ending of the movie is fine by me
is this all kind of nuclear ISM
happening this ice relax without the
trigger tips those nukes are harmless
not to mention the entire sub exploded a
minute ago you think the nukes survived
that is it gonna be Revenge of the Nerds
or the Dark Knight obviously this isn't
even a real choice when it comes to
movies but this movie really saying that
Ramsey wants either of these guys at
ease her only choices in life is she
even considering going out with one of
them I would have loved it if she
suddenly had a girlfriend or a great
worm you've heard me say you never turn
your back on family nope never heard you
say that once in one movie it's a new
concept you just invented right now
well I finally figured kill my car I
came in
[Music]
I believe that's the cyber-terrorist
known as cypher I know
Franklin Harry stay the case when the
mojo meet him order move you are nine
hours behind the toughest target you
have ever traveled how'd you get your
balls with fries enough got to keep
moving that's the secret walking is good
Fighting's better things best
Eva's phone Cindy honey I want to buy
them all I will have them all or take
none she's confessed oh shoot the glass